I'm just going to steal the ingredients
of it the particular question actually
asks you justify the great really really
simple but I'm going to go step burn up
because it's not that much with me to
find equation of the tangent to this
curve at this point or at this x value i
should say okay so what I'm trying to
find is what's the equation of the
tangent it would be just as equal to
find the equation of the normal what
would i do that's different most urgent
attention than Allah yeah the gradients
what about the radiance they're most
likely good yes sir once I find the
gradient if I just leave it as these
I'll get the tangents gradient i should
say the derivative if I want the no
longer than negative reciprocal so
that's all that will change the process
would be identical other one so let's
give this a go I have a graph i've got
an x coordinate if i want a tangent you
don't need to write this part down but
where I'm heading is this okay that's
where I'm headed ok I want a point and I
want a gradient that's what I need I'm
going to start with the easy thing first
I have been supplied with x1 I can
calculate y one just by pop it right
into this question no fancy calculus
required so that will give me the
coordinates in this case what am I
actually getting can anyone how good are
you with your radiance can you read this
off here i'll do the substitution for
you so you can see this is a sign of 2.3
or two which is pi on three you might at
this stage still need to recalibrate a
wait how many degrees is that it's to
plan 3 on 2 to 5 30 to this final three
it is right yeah
yeah what am I done where's x.x is on
the numerator ride three times do you
want me to do an exercise I'll write it
I mine anyway just moans it there's the
X and there's the odd too yep so this is
planetary you might need to think okay
that's 60 degrees sine of 60 degrees
really ought to write root 3 on 2
there's my y-coordinate that's easy I've
got my x1 I got my y1 now I've got to
get to my gradient okay so dy/dx this is
about as simple as it gets without just
giving the results that need to be
quoted you've got chain rule happening
in here so I need the derivative of the
inside function what's the dream at the
inside I've done the inside now I do the
outside sign turns into cosine right so
I'm going to go cause of X onto ok
there's the gradient function not to be
confused with the gradient the grain is
at a particular point you can't for
example and this is a common error we
believe how common is here it is a lot
of people say this one cool I've got
everything I need this is y minus root 3
or two and then they put this here
yeah yeah people do this now what's
going on what's going on we are
misunderstanding the difference between
great and that's a number versus a
gradient function right you're putting
values into it I need to actually supply
in that okay this doesn't make sense you
can't even actually do the substitution
now because I've got 2 x's fighting
around what a visit not a straight line
okay so don't do it like that evaluate
the gradient flow study I'm now going to
state my gradient therefore M is equal
to and i distinguish between these two I
safety why mdx there's my function and
then i say m that's a number i'm putting
that into something right so a half that
cause our and again it's still exon 2 so
it's still final group you may still
need to recalibrate cause of how many
degrees again 60 degrees plus 60 is a
half so a half times a half gives you a
quarter okay with that I've got on my
pieces now that's it so all i need to
say is ok um y minus y1 equals M outside
of X minus 200 you care about now this
is going to happen again and again
because we're dealing with trig
functions and we actually want exact
values you're going to get two nasty
things happening again and again namely
pi is going to be in there and sons are
going in there and there's not really
much you can do to avoid that I mean if
you want we can get rid of the fractions
what would have to multiply through by
I don't think that would do it I have to
go 12 19 if I wanted it in general form
because that and that are going to give
you 12 why don't we just do it for the
sake of it because general form is the
most if they require a forum general
form is probably the most common so
let's multiply through that gives me
this
I tend to do X is positive
there you go all of the least sociable
characters in mathematics or vol
together in a single equation and that's
my ax plus dy plus C I've done that's it
there's your equation okay now a comment
just as a follow-up just since it's
there I'm going to mention this let's
draw this can we draw this really let's
have a look what is this thing going
through this life we know what sine X on
two years how does it differ how would
you describe its verbally it's different
from sign it the period is so the way i
like to think about it is if you just
have a regular sign it right you will
get exactly one copy of the curve from
north of 2 pi up and down okay if you do
this you are going to get not one copy
but half a copy from 0 to 2pi oh of
course if i went the other way this is
twice as frequent so from 0 to 2pi you
get 12 right so I always read that
number i read that is my frequency and
that helps me remember wait is it is it
squashed is except this is stretched so
I've got not 2 pi that's a boring back
that's okay right where's to
powerbreathe
it's two thirds of the way to the
stationary point do you agree with that
because there's play is my stationary
point so if I go one two finger right
there so if I were to draw this tangent
line I'm expecting that ok now we're not
quite there yet because we haven't done
with integration yet but a very common
question would be ok hence determine the
area here that's a very very common
question and it's not hard to get you
can see what I would have to do you
could do it as a subtraction or areas
you work out this one we work out that
one and then off to currently ok but
these are the kinds of places where it's
going this is this is just the warmup
it's like what can you do with this